Deep in the
Scottish Highlands,
there's a castle where the
faithful reside.
Their goal, win a quarter of a million dollars.
But hidden amongst them...
are three traitors.
Exciting, isn't it?
You will need the
strength of a lion
and the stealth of a fox.
You might know me
from The Bachelor.
I am from Survivor.
Big Brother: All Stars.
Below Deck.
I know if I was a
traitor right now,
I would be a f---king wreck.
You're gonna confront her.
When you're saying
her name all day.
Honey, I'm looking for every excuse to get you gone!
Boom!
(Screams)
I think you're a traitor.
I trusted you.
(Scream)
I’m telling you either
banish me or murder me.
I’m done.
Close the coffins.
In this game,
the person
sitting next to you
may smile and
smile and be a villain.
I wouldn't pick that outfit,
so I don't think I trust your judgment completely.
Let’s talk about that!
I can manipulate them.
Do you think I'm a traitor?
Game faces are on.
Go! Go!
(Screams)
Woo!
There are traitors
amongst you.
You think you
know who they are?
So, trust no one.
And you thought The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
was bad.
(Laughter)